on ne bouge pas pendant les guerres de
bush pendant le génial quelle est votre
première pensée lorsque vous vous
retrouvez face à une femme séduisante
les civils honte
ouais ouais c'est l'incident ces
désagréments elle quand même adriana lit
depuis que j'ai rencontré christian je
ne pense plus à rien lorsque je me
trouve en face d'un homme séduisant
vous croyez pas alors bon bacon continue
le lieu idéal pour une étreinte pour
vous bon cachet elle répond qu'une
paille
là elle dit le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte c'est partout si je suis avec
la bonne personne mais c'est intéressant
de voir que mon gars tu es une ouverture
l'endroit question l'endroit où vous
seriez incapable de faire l'amour
parce que vous pensez l'amour c'est
simplement faire le coït mais moines
l'amour c'est aussi dans le regard donc
faire partout oui c'est vrai une zone
aménagée bien et les français on est
comme des sauvages
j'en ai répondu dans l'espace elle a dit
dans les stages pouvait pas faire
l'amour dans l'espace tout ce que
j'aurais peur je vous dis bord des
avions
alors je vous préférez draguer ou vous
faire draguer plus deux mais elle sait
se faire draguer est ce que vous
préférez largué ou vous faire larguer
salariés à manger rien à l'objet
d'accords avec celle qu'il a celle qui
part est ce que vous préférez embrasser
ou vous faire embrasser embrasser elle
aussi est sous préfet rey caresser ou
vous faire caresser
j'aime bien est-ce qu'ils aient encore
des fantasmes que vous n'avez pas
réalisé
si j'en ai oui j'en ai pas réalisé non
dits oui beaucoup
faouzi connais quand même que sans fard
et et carragher faut arrêter de régime
fiscal répond il faut arrêter de
regarder la télé si vous deviez choisir
la moitié d'une femme vous prendriez le
haut ou le bas la moitié d'une femme
ouais on peut envoyer le haut ou plus
bas le haut le bas
mais la femme n'existe pas en une notice